dr alimata diarra nama a représentante
de l' oms
oa burkina faso un bonjour docteur merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt
france alors on l'a dire des essais
cliniques sont en cours au burkina faso
quand peut-on espérer avoir les
résultats de ces essais mais je pense
que les chercheurs dans les dix ans
d'après la préfecture contre il dans un
mois à peu près on aura des résultats
déjà on aura des résultats de l'équipe
de crâne avec les fibres ont été mis en
route
je me réjouis du fait que le burkina et
adhérer à l'initiative mondiale
solidarity trial et de que l'on aime et
a mis en place avec ses partenaires un
petit a permettra de donner une valeur
une valeur sans pitié
on réduit pas qu'il part en cours et le
docteur on l'a dit un le burkina faso a
opté pour usage de la chloroquine une
bonne initiative selon vous vous savez à
la fin des traitements spécifiques à la
fois d'un traitement spécifique aux
commandes et beaucoup beaucoup de
traitements canton cours
d'expérimentation donc louer net
encourage les internautes à 100 et
attend d'avoir des résultats probants
afin de pouvoir recommander recommandé
de manière spécifique à l'hôtel
médicaments la nature au pied de la
nitro me fie à tous elle a promis si en
fin de partie de l'arsenal
l'om est veut voir encore en effet que
dans le burkina faso a opté pour ces
techniques et nous serons alors on l'a
dit aussi un le burkina faso a mis en
place à des mesures restrictives pour
permettre
justement de que le virus ne se propage
pas est ce que justement ces mesures
marchent au burkina faso privé de le
président de la république dans son
adresse adaptant le vin le débat avait
déjà annoncé pas on a mis en place le
mans toutes ces régions qui présentent
au moins et à tous ceux dont au moins un
cas de convives d'une noce
maintenant je pense que le temps nous le
dira mais ce qui est sûr que la
sensibilisation continue de du public de
l'eau que tout le monde qui va permettre
d'avoir des résultats
des résultats probants il sait bien que
celui de murray est recommandée
évidemment ça doit avoir une durée dans
le temps et tous ceux qui seraient à
prendre doivent être bien informé et je
sais pas que c'est fait à foix le
burkina d'emplois la stratégie de
communication chaque jour dans des
informations pour que le public soit
informé de ce qu'il faut faire et bande
attendant de voir ce que ça va donner
comme résultat de passer d'ici deux
semaines en aura on pourrait encore à
évaluer et qui voici le gouvernement
d'érable et devra prendre d'autres
mesures plus contraignantes et bien
relâché un peu comme ont été pris ces
mesures prises par le gouvernement par
la population il fallait pour débuter
cette apathie là le confinement n'a
jamais les populations ne sont pas
habitués à cela a des implications
sociales économiques et mais comme je le
dis il faut communiquer il faut que la
population comprenne le bien fondé de la
mesure et y adhèrent non pas comment tu
apprends que ça commence à prendre
grâce à la communication qui est fait au
quotidien et on espère que ça continue
ça va continuer jusqu'à ce que le sucre
4 qu'une évaluation utile
bon bah on va on va réduire le
confinement ou alors il n'y a pas de
résultats probants manquez pas les
gouttes mesures à prendre
merci beaucoup d'autres
rallye matin a dit rana d'avoir répondu
à nos questions cet après midi sur rc
france elle rappelle que vous êtes
représentante de l' oms au burkina faso
merci beaucoup